oh good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast to a very special
gorgeous delightful stunt stunning
episode with somebody we love here at
the toast somebody who's kind of like so
in the news right now like Scandal it's
Stussy I know I'm in the news right now
because of scandival it's so weird it's
like all the like um the outside players
that technically have nothing to do with
it like I have nothing to do with it
that's not true because you are
responsible for the most pointed the
most iconic line you selfish egotistical
piece of [__] because that's literally
exactly what it was I feel like proud of
myself I've been knowing I knew Sandoval
was what he is like I knew but like some
people like thought he was cute and like
some people of the show poop fans of the
show like like to watch him like I've
been knowing forever and I feel like you
have too no I always got so frustrated
watching the show because I'm like God
he seems like such a hero when I watch
it but like no I know you know and so to
be honest ever since you left the show I
haven't really craved your presence
there because the show was not good like
for for a considerable amount of time
until obviously this whole thing
happened and I did kind of crave someone
who was on the right right side of
history for so many years and that was
you wait do you know how good that feels
to be on the right side of History I
feel like so often I'm not same
literally same oh that feels amazing
yeah no I I do keep saying that like
what a wasted opportunity this was you
know if I if there was one season I
would have liked to have been in yeah
duh probably would have been this one so
I could have just given like a big old I
Told You So a hundred percent and I
asked Jax this when he was on the
podcast and he was actually pretty
honest I said like is there any sort of
fomo with not foam or even like a little
resentment about like the show becoming
literally the biggest thing in pop
culture and the show was built off the
backs of people like you and Jax yeah is
there any sort of like of course there
are moments where it's like oh wow like
seeing how big it's gotten it's like
when we're not there I think that that's
human nature of course I mean I would be
so not okay a little bit then you get
insecure about like was I not good
enough did I not do like it's a weird
it's it's a weird convoluted kind of
nuancy feeling because it's like I'm
happy that I'm not in that in that but
at the same time oh I miss it makes you
miss it a little bit yeah yeah and I
feel like I don't know I feel like just
based as like an outsider watching your
life on social media like you really
look like you're thriving you're
pregnant again you look so beautiful
that like you don't I feel like for a
while like the show was like really the
center of your universe and now you have
such a full life outside of it yeah no
like because when I think about like
what would that be like to film again my
life is so different where yes
Vanderpump Rules used to be the center
of my world I
I organized my life around the show yeah
so and now I I just I I couldn't imagine
going to the places and doing the things
that would be required from being on a
show like fan or pump rules yeah I have
to imagine at like the height of it when
you guys were so young and like really
just like drinking all the time like it
was so toxic though I totally missed
drinking all the time I know you know we
only have a little while left yeah how
far along are you
um
um seven months and you're having a boy
yeah and are you so excited no
ridiculously excited because I am not
the favorite in the house uh Beau is
hartford's favorite Daddy's girl and
it's about time I am number one that's
hurtful I'm not gonna lie I've cried
multiple multiple times I mean sobbing
dry heaving crying because I feel left
out in my own house I mean you literally
gave birth no it's like she doesn't
understand she doesn't realize she will
one day I'm gonna slap the sense into
her she will understand one day and I
feel like that's like a huge part of
growing up it's like you actually end up
like having so much gratitude and
respect for your parents like dealing
with you I'm looking forward to that
yeah no your time is coming sassy well
you look great you're just like doing
the most honestly you exhaust me like
I'm a deeply lazy person no you're not
and I'm not even pregnant no Claudia
you're not no no I really I'm like at my
core I'm like a lazy slob and I love
that about myself it's like a
Cornerstone in my personality you are
doing the most and you're So Pregnant
okay this is the thing my first
pregnancy was during covid I was not
allowed to leave my house all I could do
was sit around and watch Outlander the
Great British Bake Off show and bake
sweets and eat them all day long sounds
like heaven I didn't get to put on
outfits yeah I didn't do anything so I
that was one of the reasons I was scared
to get pregnant for a second time
because I have all of this it's like I
feel like a little triggered like yeah
oh my God does that mean that I'm gonna
be confined to my house again and so I
am trying to do the most because the
first time I did nothing that's a good
explanation no and now you're like
dressing up your Bump which you never
got to do because you were probably in
pajamas all day yes and you look so good
on tour like I came to see your show it
was so good you looked like I wanted to
kill you like look you so beautiful and
you wear shoes that like I could never
wear and you're pregnant well that is
because they make me feel so much better
about myself like when I put a heel on I
mean I insulate my my self-esteem just
Rises so immensely so does mine because
like then my legs look longer like I
can't really see the cellulite like that
I get and there's nothing worse than
when you're on tour and then you see
everyone posting the videos of you and
they're all from down low and you're
like I'm a troll I'm a beast I hate
myself so yeah the higher the heel that
is such a niche reference and I could
not agree more that is probably one of
my least favorite things about being a
performer is the fact that I'm up on an
elevated surface and everybody taking a
photo of me is below me yeah like and I
don't even wear dresses or skirts if I
did that would probably bring like
another element of panic but like the
chin the it's the angle it's horrible
horrible it's offensive yeah well I
haven't noticed you've just been looking
truly radio well I'm only reposting the
ones that that I look good in I
understand and I respect that I really
truly do well I saw the show it was so
good I have to ask you something because
I feel like we're actually in like a
similar position with our husbands like
okay when your husband came out on stage
oh my God like the girlies in the
audience were losing their minds like
they're obsessed and he's hysterical
don't get me wrong but like he wasn't
like doing anything crazy and they were
like loving it and that's how I feel
about my husband like when he comes on
the podcast and stuff it's like he
doesn't even do anything and everyone's
like that was the best episode ever like
we need Ben on every episode I'm like
really like I'm sitting right here I'm
sitting right here I was like doing the
most and nobody even knows I'm carrying
this yeah no literally and it's like
it's kind of hard not to become
resentful do you agree you know what I
think of it as this I feel like because
our husbands are really good people and
people sense that I actually genuinely
think that so they could do the least
and and people receive still yes and
people would still love it because I
think that you can just sense and see
that like wow those are really good men
yeah Beau really is the best no he is
he's the best person that I know how did
you guys meet
um Kristen and Katie introduced us oh
damn everything comes back to veteran
parole everything's always [__] comes
back how did they know him how did they
know him
um just mutual friends like he would
hang out in some of like the circles
that like Kristen would hang out with
like other groups of friends that she
had and I remember she showed me his
Instagram and I was like oh he's hot and
he looks different than anyone I've ever
dated before and that's how that
happened you know one of the great
Crimes of the last few years is we never
really got so much bow on Vanderpump
Rules it was like one or two seasons but
he was you guys weren't engaged yet like
oh you actually you got engaged on the
show but like there was just like not
enough like we really never got to like
live with you and Bo but like how
amazing is that for you but like but
also we're living in people's heads
where we stopped where it's you know we
put it on it long enough for the
producers to be like you know what we
we're gonna really need to give you a
bad season yeah let's like dig let's dig
deep it's so true we never got a bow Bad
season yeah he just lives he's like
permanently Frozen in everyone's Minds
yeah at the age of like whatever he was
back then yeah that's gorgeous
now the age-old question you know I'm
sure everyone asks like return to
reality TV question mark
um I think that if there was something
that again I didn't feel like I had to
change my life to be involved in yeah
then I would like I I really do miss it
I love it but I just don't want to
disrupt my life yeah like it really does
actually like it gives me anxiety when I
think about because I really try and
imagine what it would be like to film
again and if I were to change my life
that then affects your relationship and
it affects your children it just it
affects family members would you put
your kids on the show it depends on the
show yeah that's fair that's fair yeah
um by the way I don't know if you want
to respond but Jax had a lot to say
about you when he came on the toes I
heard because I'm a toaster so obviously
I listened so I was like oh you know
yeah I honestly I didn't think he said
anything like incriminating or bad say
anything bad he just didn't say the
truth that's right so he basically said
like he really doesn't know why you're
upset with him and you know it was if
it's about the wedding it was just you
know like his kids passport last minute
like didn't come through this is the
thing I would understand that
um it's the fact that you know me and
Bowen texted him and Brittany weeks
prior saying um we hear you're talking a
little [__] oh about how you're not
gonna be coming to our wedding which is
interesting because you are with rcp'd
and I'm you're our closest some of our
closest friends so I what the [__] is
that and they denied and denied denied I
gave them the opportunity to back out to
back out yes and they didn't and then as
I was getting on the plate the day I
left for the airport to fly to Italy I
got a text from Brittany so like that's
it that feels
um way more hurtful yes there are lots
of friends that couldn't make it to my
wedding and you all couldn't make it to
my wedding you're such a small wedding
yes and I think that was a huge part of
why it hurt even more because I had to
cut so many family members so many
people that I would have loved to have
been there so they took up two spaces
right and then we're just you know Jax
was doing doing what Jags does yeah and
texting talking [__] well that's that's
really hurtful to talk [__] about
someone's wedding and for him to say my
what really bothers me is when it feels
weird to even be talking about because
it's like a year later and I understand
people are like get over it I'm like I
am over it but that doesn't mean that I
have to go be besties with people yeah
um I think What Hurts the Most too is
that he's like weirder went to their
first wedding I'm like oh he did say
that we didn't get to have one we
literally just signed papers and in your
backyard right in Katie's backyard
during my baby shower during covid with
less than 10 people and I had
specifically said you guys are just
witnessing us signing these papers this
is not our wedding we're still hoping we
can get married in Italy like they knew
that it wasn't a white wedding is that a
[__]
I thought that was her first husband
yeah listen like I I do I miss them at
times and like I I love catching like I
I follow them still and see what they're
up to in their lives and Cruz is so cute
and all of that but like they hurt me
yep they really did yeah and it feels
like I don't I can't trust them yeah
you're totally entitled to like be upset
and I had a feeling I love Jax but like
you know I and I relate to Jackson This
Way like I see things through my own
lens and sometimes like when somebody
else will recount a story to me I'm like
no that's literally not how it happened
I'm like I'm telling you I was there and
I'm not a reliable witness you know
Jackie always says that like if I tell
Jackie's story she has to like hear it
from someone else like make sure I'm not
lying and I'm not lying I just like
that's how I experienced it I swear 100
no there are times Bo and I joke all the
time because like Bo will remember
something and I'm like you're
remembering that I told you this story
you weren't even there no he's like yes
I was there I'm like you're not there
you were not there that was a girl's
night bow oh speaking of girls night we
got some gorgeous
um Instagram story footage from you
about the new sandwich shop can you give
us an update like when is that it looked
ready to go I feel like it's gonna open
um this summer I feel like it's like not
far off it's so beautiful it's like
Parisian Chic meets like Montecito
Jackie and I both said when when you
posted those Instagram stories
aesthetically it reminded me a lot of
you like very Parisian and there's like
blue and white yeah yeah yeah it was
very sausage it was beautiful no I I
mean I'm so happy for them and I'm happy
for myself because I feel like there
aren't that many good sandwich shops in
Los Angeles so I'm like y'all are gonna
be on Postmates right right no Uber Eats
I I just you think you'll get free
sandwiches or you're gonna support local
female-one businesses I'm gonna support
yeah couldn't be me if I know someone
with a restaurant I'm like yeah I'll be
there 10 o'clock sir doesn't even give
me free food really I have bled out for
sir that's do you eat it sir if I were
to go into dinner I'd get a bill I would
get it 100 yeah that's like disgusting
it's a little wild but it's okay two
things one can you pull your mic a
little bit closer to your mouth Yes I'm
so sorry and normally I have headphones
on so you can hear so I can hear when
I'm yeah and my second thing is what is
your current relationship status with
lvp
um every time I see her she has been so
lovely and so nice
um I think the last time I saw her we
went to her house for her for Pandora's
son's birthday and I'm great good great
okay good yeah now you are a big pop
culture girly which is why you want to
[__] yeah yeah let's do this you're one
of my favorite people to co-host with
because there's no like
you know with Ben sometimes I have to
like be like so then this happened and
then she's from that movie you remember
her we watched it on the plane like yeah
he you don't require any sort of
now before we dive in I do have one Sex
in the City story and when I have a
co-host on I always like to ask them
their thoughts on the Sex and the City
characters because I feel like it sets a
good because I have like there I have a
hot I have hot taste oh no I we have hot
takes although I don't think my takes
are hot anymore I think that we've all
collectively agreed that Carrie is the
[__] word okay so that's pretty much
I just wanted to make sure that you
agreed with that because like I hate no
if when I tell you like when I meet
women who are like no Carrie's the best
I'm like you need to be weeded out of
the world no you obviously haven't
re-watched the show as like an adult
correct with responsibilities and
friends because as a kid sure yes she's
the most fabulous and she's like the
main character so you're like oh she's
the best then you re-watch as you get
older you're like wait this [__] is the
[__] worst so selfish so so selfish
so financially irresponsible yes that
could never be me like literally
has that episode where she I always
bring this up
Charlotte to give her ring are you
[__] kidding me yeah no it's like if
that episode were to happen nowadays no
no no cancel growing up is realizing
Carrie was the villain of that show yeah
and honestly we grow up thinking like
Miranda's the worst no Miranda's the
best yep I know whenever I say that
people are like you're just trying to be
a contrarian I'm like no I'm not no I'm
sorry Miranda's so funny she's such
she's so cynical which what makes is
what makes her funny and I feel like
that's very New Yorker of her and I
think we all just judge her because she
had like weird outfits and like a weird
haircut and like that wasn't the vibe we
were more into like the fabulosity of
the show and she doesn't really
contribute in terms of like fabulousness
yeah but she is and I'm not talking
about the new show because the new
Show's horrible I'm talking about like
the OG show she was the best her and
Samantha no I mean I honestly I love
Charlotte too me too me too but she's
not my favorite
but she's not my least favorite I mean I
don't have a favorite honestly I'm
thinking about it I don't have I mean
besides least favorite yeah but you know
Carrie sucks okay I just wanted to like
down the chair because like I can't I
can't with people who are like Carrie
I'm such a carry I'm like okay so you're
the worst
all right you guys Tessa's gonna help me
she's gonna do what we do best the past
five stories that you need to know
today's episode is sponsored by
betterhelp it's so easy to get caught up
on what everyone else needs from you and
never take a moment to think about what
you need from yourself I mean everyone
knows I'm such a giver I never think
about myself I'm kidding but like when
you're a friend a sister a wife a
daughter it's just hard to like you know
really always be thinking about yourself
and taking care of your mental health is
so important when we spend all of our
time giving it really can leave us
feeling stretched thin and burned out
therapy gives you the tools to find more
balance in your life so you can keep
supporting others without leaving
yourself behind if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely done online it's designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire and get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapists for any time no additional
charge that's the best part of better
help I think like when you go to therapy
I think it's really common that you meet
a therapist and it's just not the right
match they're an amazing therapist but
it's just not the right match for you
it's so it's so personal it's more
personal than comedy so betterhelp takes
all that awkwardness out of it it's done
entirely online if you want to switch to
somebody who you think you might be like
better suited with it's just not awkward
there's no waiting rooms there's no
awkward phone calls it's done entirely
online so whatever Medium you're most
comfortable with like if you want to
talk on the phone if you want to video
chat if you want to text you can do all
that with your therapist from betterhelp
it's so accessible it's more affordable
than therapy find more balance with
better help visit betterhelp.com toast
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash toast betterhelp.com
toast t-o-a-s-t thank you better help
for sponsoring today's episode today's
episode is brought to you by roback I
think it's safe to say everyone is
talking about roback whether it's their
performance hoodies their polos or their
Q Zips we always make sure to recommend
rollback for the man in your life if you
want your man looking good then get him
row back now of course the man in your
life is important but what's more
important than you nothing and robax uh
scores so many of their items are
amazing we're excited to recommend for
all of the ladies they just relieved
active skorts and dresses and we are
obsessed it's perfect for a day out on
the courts a walk with your dog a nice
jog you know it's summertime we've got
to be looking out for our thighs and
wearing a squirt is my favorite summer
time hack I deal with chub rub I deal
with chafing and wearing a skort is just
the best there's nothing better and it's
such a cute look you don't have to worry
about like the wind blowing up your
skirt there's a million reasons why you
should wear a skirt and the one from
roback is so cute their dresses are so
cute the active dresses feature their
trademarked GTG technology so you don't
have to take your dress all the way off
when you got to go to the bathroom their
liner also doesn't ride up it has great
stretch and hidden pockets for all of
your Essentials which is the best their
joggers and Hoodie sets are the softest
pieces of clothing that we own if you
want to be comfortable then these
joggers and hoodies are for you we
haven't taken them off since we received
them they're just that good with Summer
quickly approaching make sure to get
check out rollback while you're at it we
strongly recommend treating yourself as
well use code toast at roback.com for a
crazy generous 20 off your first order
of performance squirts joggers and
hoodies that's spelled r h o b a c k.com
that's 20 off with the code toast
roback.com
and the first one we have another uh
show since Friday so there was like so
much news Jackie was so jealous that you
were coming in today no wait this is so
annoying because last time I was here
Jackie wasn't here I've wanted to have
this like the three of us I know really
just do the damn thing maybe me and
Jackie were actually talking like after
she gives birth we need to do like an LA
week yes so you would be a perfect La
week person yeah don't leave me out I
promise I will get the [__] film out
I promise all right Kourtney Kardashian
has debuted her baby bump days after
announcing her pregnancy at Travis
Barker's concert so Travis Barker and
Kourtney Kardashian are welcoming a baby
two days after announcing they're
expecting their first child together the
Kardashian star gave fans a closer look
at her pregnancy she took to Instagram
on June 18th and she bared her bump but
a series of photos taken at Travis's
Blink 182 concert where she made the the
big reveal
um so there was like a lot of chatter
about the big reveal because at first
everyone was like oh my God Courtney's
pregnant let's unpack that then
everybody wanted to unpack the
announcement I think a lot of people
didn't understand like the pop culture
reference and
you think there's one thing that goes on
in her body that he doesn't know about
100 he probably could like sense her
ovulating just like from her Aura like
they're so connected there's no way like
there's no way and I don't think people
understood that like it's a reference
from his old music video where some
girls like standing outside his concert
holding a sign that says Travis I'm
pregnant so once you understand that
like you know for sure that it's not
I think that was her equivalent to like
someone like me being a basic [__] and
posting a sonogram photo on Instagram a
hundred percent I thought hers was so
creative and so cute yeah I loved it at
first I didn't understand the reference
immediately so I also was like wait is
she telling him and then some people
were like accusing them of being fraud
jumping like he actually knew this is
fake like people are so no dumb well no
stop but now that now looking at it at a
glance having all the information I
thought it was so cute do people really
think that she's gonna keep that secret
and announce announce to the world the
same time she announces to her husband
no that's so impersonal yeah and they're
so like you know they're so connected
yes and by the way she's pretty far
along she has like a bump I think once I
saw the bump I was like what do you
think she's like five months I don't
know months I like think in terms of
wheat okay I want to say like she's
giving like 17 week energy so it's
between like four and five right right I
think so is that what it is pregnancy
math makes no it [__] sucks literally
no sense and what makes less sense to me
is toddler math
oh no I'm good at that like how old is
Hartford when people ask oh I don't do
that anymore she's two and a half okay
once they turn two I don't do that
anymore okay but she was like 18. she
was 23 months yeah that confuses me but
like I guess there really is such a
difference between like a 20 month and a
22 month there is like in terms of miles
you should know because you have so many
nieces and nephews or yes so like it is
different they're so different but like
once you turn two I feel like it you're
like a kitten yeah yeah or the terrible
two is a real thing
the way I was so excited for this trip
the way I was so excited to break
Hartford in New York she's in New York
I'm like I she's gonna be like Hartford
At The Carlyle you know like Eloise at
the Plaza but like yep she's just like
I'm I can't wait I planned so many
things for her so many gorgeous
activities the way she has channeled the
brattiest version of herself and had
tantrum after tantrum we've had to leave
every dinner and lunch early oh I'm just
like I get so my blood has run cold in
public so many times because I'm just so
embarrassed do you think she's like jet
lagged
um I don't know maybe I I I just like or
it's just jokes that like you know we
did go to the plaza for teen he's like
the ghost you know when like in The
Conjuring when like a ghost latches on
to a family it's like Eloise latched
onto Hartford and you have an exorcism
100 but it has been so nice having her
here but yeah she is we keep just
looking at each other and being like
it's a phase like we'll survive we will
survive terrible twos that's why they
say terrible too and I'm sure when you
travel without her it's like so
devastating and then she's here and
she's burning it like we can't win no I
know seriously damn well I find this
news like so cute and shocking because
on this show the Kardashians
um they had spoken about her they did
like intensive IVF IUI like she got her
eggs retrieved and it just wasn't in the
cards and it was really hard on her and
she was like you know what it's in God's
plan now so to see somebody who tried so
hard and like it didn't work out and
then just like kind of you know let go
of the idea and be like what happens
happens for it to happen for her like I
actually think is so sweet and I I think
that the Kardashians can do anything
they put their minds I know like I
really what do you think can I ask you
something about that Kardashian please
have you been on The Tick Tock like path
where people are talking about how the
Kardashians are on their way out I have
and Jackie I try and swipe out of it
because I don't like that content Jackie
and I have spoken about it I don't think
that they're on their way out I think
they're definitely experiencing like
some sort of like flop era but that's
good yeah I think it's I think it's
natural it's just they haven't really
had one this like Monumental I think it
was a series of unfortunate events but
the only way to have an epic comeback
yes and to or to show any growth or
change is to have a flop era so like
everyone needs a flop era every now and
I think something like this where it's
like so wholesome this this pregnancy so
wholesome the announcement was not like
you know
tacky or it was just like really sweet I
think things like this really endear
people to the Kardashians because at the
end of the day like they are a family
and the things that are important to
them are really the things that are
important to most people like you know
loyalty and they're very you know
they're religious like faith I think a
lot of people connect to like a lot of
their core values and so something like
this I think reminds people like they're
really at the end of the day they're
just like a family yes you know Courtney
wanted to get pregnant and that was
something she struggled with that so
many people struggle with so like this
something like this I think is really
good for the family and they have had
like a hard year in terms of like public
perception I think but I don't think
they're out no foreign
what do you think about Kylie Jenner
dressing like Sophia Regina I mean I
love it Jackie had a really interesting
take on it that like totally changed my
perception of I think for a really long
time like the cool way of dressing was
like very provocative and thoughty and
that's just not a trend I'll ever
participate in one because my body limit
limits me in that
um but also it's just like not my style
no I could be the hottest [__] out
there I could look like lala can yeah
you know what I mean and I would never
dress I can't like it just I feel
uncomfortable same it's not who I am and
that's not judging other people who do
it's just not who I am and so for Sophia
Richie to make dressing modest cool is
such a powerful thing because now all
these girls used to like run around with
their tits out are now like wearing
Blazers and slacks it's actually amazing
what she's done for the culture okay I I
have a hot take let's hear it I don't
like it because I feel like that's
already the style that I've had for so
long and now that it's popular
everyone's dressing like me and now it's
gonna become unpopular and I'm still
gonna be here left dressing granny Chic
and then I'm gonna look like I'm just
behind on the trend but that is the most
you thing ever because you are proudly a
basic [__] and now the thing that
you've loved the most your style has
become the most kind of common
borderline basic yeah I guess you're
right now actually another whenever I do
like co-host some always like Jackie I
don't even think this and Jack but
Jackie and I were just talking about
this how we really feel like strongly
that you are not basic
wow you are like so different like I
feel like you marched to the beat of
your own drum like you don't give a [__]
what anyone thinks and like yeah some of
your interests like Ranch yeah it's like
basic but you really at your core like
you're not a basic person you're like
deeply original okay well I think it all
depends on on your definition of Basics
that's true because my definition of
basic is just really like being unafraid
to lean into the things that you really
love and it's like about being like
passionate and excited about things it's
like Taylor Swift energy yes I know I
know exactly you know what I mean yeah
like that's my embarrassed to be excited
about something correct like that's my
definition of basic okay so when it
comes to that I feel like I'm truly
basic that I agree with but when I think
it comes to like style and just like
aesthetic and your home like your home
is so I've never walked to Elbow I've
never been in your house but I've never
seen a house that was styled like that
by like a young Millennial woman wait
thank you that is one of the best
compliments it's like right under like
wow sassy you're a really good mom like
yeah telling me that like my whole style
yeah and the style of it is it's so
different even the house that you bought
is like an older more Charming home I
feel like all the houses in La like look
like mental institutions and windows
like you are so different in that sense
and you're so not basic in that thank
you but I understand your definition of
basic and I agree and I love that that
Taylor Swift quote like people there's
nothing worse than somebody who makes
fun of someone for being excited about
something or like why don't you just
like lower your voice like excuse me I
haven't heard that one no like people
who like tell you like calm down when
you're excited about something yeah
totally yeah
um okay the next story is I know
something you are it's like so
you like it's so something you would be
obsessed with and I think a lot of
people are really kind of quaking about
the search and rescue operation that is
underway for a submersive submersible
touring the wreck of the Titanic
basically a submarine so officials are
in a Race Against Time to find a
civilian submarine they keep calling it
a submersible and I'm not calling it
that a submarine that had five people
aboard after it went missing on Sunday
in the North Atlantic while voyaging to
the wreckage of the Titanic the 21-foot
vessel has four days of emergency
capability the leader of the search and
rescue effort said Monday afternoon as
Crews with the U.S and Canadian Coast
Guards continued scouring the ocean's
surface about 900 miles east of Cape Cod
and used sonar to listen for sounds far
below the surface which is up to 13 000
feet deep in the area so there are five
people on board the vessel which was an
expedition to view the wreckage of the
Titanic
um it was comprised of One Pilot and
four mission Specialists
um they haven't identified the five
people but they have figured out who one
of the the people is based on social
media a British businessman based in the
United United Arab Emirates his name is
Hamish Harding is one of the people on
the submarine according to a social
media post by the company he owns
so this is so today this morning I saw
um one of the people in there is a
father and son and the son is 19 years
old when I tell you I could not sleep
last night I know I could not sleep all
I I just wanted to look at these these
videos these tick tocks everything did
you see that it's they did a tour of the
summer it's not big it's it's no it's
the smallest and there's one little
round window and it the controller that
they use to control it is a PS3 excuse
me I'm not [__] joking I didn't make
this up it's in multiple tick tocks like
in itika an interview that they did
here's what I don't understand because I
saw a picture of a submarine I saw that
little window so if you're gonna go all
the way down to view the wreckage and
there's one tiny little window for five
people I don't understand the the I
don't oh and Jackie also told me a crazy
statistic so they have four days of
emergency supplies I think I saw last
night that like they have like probably
96 hours to find it
but Jackie had said like if they wanted
to build a submarine that was powerful
enough to go down and like find to use
for search and rescue it would take 30
years for that submarine to be built
like the the equipment in order to
properly like find these people actually
doesn't exist which is What's So Scary
oh my god well also I read that the most
dangerous Rescue Mission they've ever
done was 11 000 feet higher than what
this is so if they were able to find
them this will be the deepest rescue
mission right like the way like this is
if I choose if I allow myself to think
about it too much and it will be the
only thing I think about like what are
they doing right now no all I can yeah
what are they doing they're in there
right now do you think that they're at
the point where they've lost hope do you
think that they're playing games like do
you do you think that I don't I don't
know but like also and I don't want to
like get too dark okay so they say they
have four days of emergency supply so it
obviously means like food right
um and oxygen oxygen so what does that
mean well I think we're on like 60 hours
now so but what does that mean does that
mean like I don't what is what happens
when you run out of oxygen like you just
pass out and die well I don't know
exactly like the paint is it like you do
you suffocate
but like there's also let's see there's
also like still air they're like in do
you know what I mean no but it's not Ox
it's not what you can breathe it's not
what you can breathe but I also read
that right now they could be getting
hypothermia oh because they're so far
down and it's so cold down there yeah
and like oh my God there's so many
videos on Tick Tock like someone was
doing an interview and they're like he
just had lost hope he the way that he
was interviewing was like he was this
Titanic expert or submarine Titanic and
he's just like I think that something
went wrong immediately and they're not
even here anymore oh yeah like it was
like the pressure the water pressure
like crushed it or something like that
something went wrong but also the
submarine being 21 feet that's like not
big at all so you're literally looking
for a needle in a haystack because
you're so far down it's what but they're
supposed to be by the Titanic it's not
like they're scanning a hole it's so
true I'm like you hope you you we know
where they went by the way if somebody
would have asked me where the wreck of
the Titanic was I would not have said
900 miles off the coast of Cape Cod I
literally thought it was like in London
I don't know like
like I saw it from it was from London to
New York to New York but they were like
pretty close or to Boston I think but
they were like pretty close to Boston
okay I didn't realize so they were like
they were more than halfway there I
think
unless the wreckage I kind of floated
but I I just was shocked at the map
I'm just shocked at the whole thing I
feel like I can't believe we're living
in a time where this is happening like I
know it is and to know that there if
something hasn't gone wrong like if
they're still there like right now as
we're talking about this
they're working with each other on all
like I'm trying to figure out they're
going through all of the emotions and
all the like phases of like accepting
right and like you can't just like
disembark like and start swimming
because you're literally so far down
right yeah no you were just stuck in
there and I think if you even like went
swimming like not swimming but like if
you if they had to press the water the
water pressure would kill you like yeah
it's like freezing it's so like the sea
level shout out into space right right
so and this is a private Mission oh my
God the bathroom no I was thinking about
that there is like a little toilet on
that one right but it's you're in there
with it and there's five people yeah
oh my God like um it's my worst
nightmare like
but this isn't like an official
government it was like a private company
doing this 250 000 a ticket
that's insane to see through one little
window I mean Taylor had a really good
point because I was I asked her about it
last night and she was like Taylor
Striker and she was like you know these
billionaires like really wealthy people
it's like normal
CDs yeah it's a thrill-seeking thing
like they're they get to experience so
much of life that it's like what can we
push push that's like everyone go into
space that's also like 250 Grand a
ticket I would never I would I would
never I have zero desire honestly I have
zero desire to leave my house on a
Friday night a hundred percent like and
you know how uncomfortable that rocket
ship is like let's say something
happened it's like chill in space for a
while like there's no bed there's no TV
like I am so content here on Earth Earth
has everything I need agreed Uber
seamless Meats like there's really
there's nothing I don't need that it
doesn't exist for me here I know I agree
I agree so I will never be and maybe
it's just that I'm outrage Rich enough
but I don't need to to go to space no
it's not about being rich enough it's no
it's about being happy in your life like
the these people who pay a quarter of a
million dollars to go to space for 30
seconds like seriously what's the point
wild this story is so sad it's so scary
and it's just like if you think about it
too long like it's like no that's what I
mean like if I if I allow my brain to
really go there and really think about
it I fully spiral and like I I really do
recommend everyone looking up like
searching on Tick Tock and seeing all
these videos also everyone in the
comment section is like really Savage
and funny and I'm like this is not this
time it's not the time this is not the
time like I'm not one to be like
inappropriate yeah
I never feel that way but like yeah you
guys they're dying yeah and do you think
like I mean then you also have to think
about like the human nature element of
it it could very quickly turn like Lord
of the Flies you know once you know that
like things are
yeah you know that the oxygen is going
to run out so maybe you kill the other
four so that you can have more oxygen
right until people find you God no like
it's that's what happens like you're
kind of audio the way that my brain did
not go there you're like survivor's
Instinct kicked kicks in you know
there's only so much food so much oxygen
like
yeah wow yeah oh my God totally separate
I have to tell you the craziest thing
that happened to me last night I people
need to know what happened to me okay
now let me set the scene okay
I read the spookiest thriller book
before bed last night it was so good
good it was called Never Lie by Freda
McFadden I highly recommend
so I'm just like feeling on edge like
before bed I shouldn't have read it
before bed but it was so good so Ben
gets home he had been to dinner we like
hang out whatever we're going to sleep
it's really early it's like 10 30 but we
have a long day today because we're
driving to Boston so I was like you know
what
let's go to bed early 10 30. my husband
like one of the things I hate most about
him 10 seconds he could fall asleep yeah
no I I guess nothing too I know I have
to take like massive amounts of
melatonin like Unison don't worry it's
pregnancy safe my daughter that's good
to know yeah so I'm just like annoyed
and it's like 10 30 it's 11 it's 11 30.
it's 12. and at about like 12 30 Ben is
passed out I'm like like I'm not asleep
but I'm like feel I'm starting to get
tired but I'm like you know let me pee
so I don't turn on any of the lights and
I'm sitting in the pitch black on the
toilet and I'm peeing and I'm just kind
of like looking down and I look up and
in the doorway of the bathroom there's a
man
okay there's a man standing there okay
and I let out the most blood curdling
scream it was actually you know I've
never been in like think you know knock
one thank God like immense danger before
but that's I never know I never knew
what sound my voice would make if I was
ever in like fight or flight right I I
can't I don't even remember it was blood
like scream and as I'm screaming I
realize that the man in front of me has
been
it's Pitch Black
so Ben doesn't see me on the toilet he's
trying to pay but he didn't know you
were in there he didn't know I was in
there and I didn't know he was in there
so he's trying to go pee and he hears
this like Babylon fire crazy
and Ben then lets out like he was just
trying to pee in its pitch black he just
hears a woman screaming he starts
screaming like his kind of danger like
danger danger
scream
what does his sound like honestly I was
so triggered I don't even remember we
just both I'm sitting on the toilet he's
standing in the doorway of the bathroom
we're both just screaming and you know
after a few seconds we both realized
we're not in danger and that the person
the woman screaming in the bathroom is
me and the Man Standing in the doorway
is Ben but when I tell you like it took
me 25 seconds to like realize what was
going on to calm down I literally called
my doorman because I'm like our
neighbors are gonna think it was like an
actual if somebody had if you had woken
up in the middle of the night with a
knife over you that's the sounds we were
making correct okay I called the doorman
and I was like if anybody calls you
about a scream like it was me we're fine
it was just like a misunderstanding but
I'm like I couldn't decide whose fault
it was and I also couldn't decide whose
experience was more scary it was clearly
Ben's fault like he didn't realize
getting out of bed that I wasn't in the
bed
but I can imagine for Ben it's pitch
black he's just going to pee and all of
a sudden he hears like the most insane
like
Mara Vibes with your hair what's
tomorrow is that the woman's Ring The
Ring yeah yeah
I am a firm belief like I believe my
experience was more scary like to just
look up and see the shadow of the man
standing in your in your bathroom in the
middle of the night when you've already
read this book I don't feel like it's a
competition it's no it's very equal no I
think it was very equal whose fault was
it he well it definitely wasn't your
fault yes it definitely wasn't your
fault whether it was anyone's fault is
questionable that's Up For Debate but
like it wasn't yours and the most insane
thing like I'm shaking Stacy like I I'm
like on the verge of tears I don't know
whether to laugh or cry because the
whole thing is so absurd but I'm like
I'm actually like shaking I'm like Ben
like we get back in bed I'm like he's
passed out I'm like you don't want to
talk about what just happened he's like
so tired I'm like are you doing I'm like
are you okay like you're asleep right
now how can you sleep at a time like
this oh passed out and then this morning
he woke up I'm like we need to talk
about last night he's like what happened
I'm like what wait like it's a fight
that you guys got in you know that were
like that you you went to bed angry
after Trump said we need to discuss it
after 10 seconds he's like oh yeah that
was crazy I'm like crazy
that was psychotic oh my God I totally
forgot about that until this morning
thank you for letting me like it was the
craziest I have to separating through
before bed don't you get nervous or like
embarrassed that like your neighbors
might think that like you're having a
domestic like something dispute like
yeah the thing is people in my building
are so
um like not nosy like they keep to
themselves but then I'm like
I wish you would be nosy because I'm
screaming in the middle of the night
good point good point yeah and the next
I did find out this morning somebody did
call which like made me I was like oh
thank God because something actually
happened I want you know everyone
calling once I scream yeah she made me
feel good but by the second we stopped
screaming my first instinct that's like
so New York I was like I have to call
the doorman because like it's such a
crazy it was such a crazy sound that I
made
and I was worried about my neighbors
sounds like it was like a wild animal
Screech it was it was not human sorry
that that happened to you isn't that a
crazy story sorry today's episode is
brought to you by Squarespace it is the
space to sell anything Squarespace has
the tools that you need to get your
business off the ground including
e-commerce templates Inventory
management a simple checkout process and
secure payments so whatever you're
selling Squarespace has merchandising
features to make your products look
their best online you gotta check out
squarespace.com toast for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use the
offer code toast to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
so whatever the reason is for wanting to
start a website I feel like you need a
website these days Squarespace is really
the best of the best I've used many
different platforms I built a lot of
websites over the years and I can tell
you confidently Squarespace is the
easiest one I don't have a background in
computer science or engineering but for
my job I find myself really needing to
make a lot of different websites and I
love squares Squarespace especially for
e-commerce they make it so easy
eCommerce websites can be like really
unnecessarily confusing and hard to make
but they have so many different great
tools at Squarespace like the traffic
overview you can see how your visits
unique visitors and Page views are
trending you can get insight into the
top traffic sources product device
products device types browsers operating
systems but what I really love about
Squarespace is their content ownership
you own all the content that you put in
on the Squarespace platform they offer a
one-click data portability again if you
want to check out Squarespace go to
squarespace.com toast for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use the
offer code toast to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
that code is toast
t-o-a-s-t today's episode is also
brought to you by vegamore we are always
trying to do right by our bodies so when
it comes to hair and scap scalp Health
finding a product that actually works
and is made with clean ingredients
always seems like a trade-off but with
vagamore we get products that are made
with clean ingredients and give us
visibly healthy hair and scalp Jackie
has been on the clean Beauty trend for a
while for uh her hair she's had a lot of
different regrowth phases because she
was you know pregnant and then
postpartum and I've recently very sadly
started to experience hair shedding so
I'd never really been looking for
products before that helped with that
and my immediate go-to was vegamore
because Jackie loved it so many of you
guys recommend it we love the grow kit
so the value kits like the grow
Essentials kit is where you get to try
more than one amazing product but you
also get it at a great savings when you
sign up for a monthly subscription you
save more and you never run low on the
products that you need to take care of
your hair the key is consistency for
your routine
so if you want healthy looking hair use
vagamore we use the grow I use it daily
the hair Serum is amazing the shampoo
and conditioner is also amazing too
we're using it daily my scalp is
flourishing there's a noticeable
difference in my shedding they sell one
bottle of that grow serum every 15
seconds on their website that's how good
that stuff is give yourself the hair you
never thought you could have with
vegamore for a limited time the toast
listeners get 20 off their first order
by going to vegamore.com toast and using
Code toast at checkout that's vegamore
spelled
v-e-g-a-m-o-u-r.com slash toast code
toast to save 20 off your first order
that's
v-e-g-a-m-o-u-r.com slash toast code
toast t-o-a-s-t thank you big more for
sponsoring today's episode
a crazy story just trying to segue here
Bebe rexa was hospitalized the crate
like actually the craziest thing and the
whole thing was caught on camera I saw
so she says she's good after being hit
in the face with a phone on stage which
set doesn't sound as bad as it actually
is so Bebe rexa was struck in the face
and injured by a cell phone during a
concert in New York City and the man who
threw it has been arrested so she was
knocked to the ground during her Sunday
night show at the Rooftop at Pier 17 in
lower Manhattan the phone hit Bibi on
the forehead in the middle of a song
splitting her eyebrow and requiring
stitches she was escorted immediately
off the stage and treated by a medical
team at the venue as seen in footage
on Tick Tock so the guy who threw the
phone his name is Nicholas malvagna he's
27 he's from Manalapan New Jersey and he
is accused of throwing the phone he was
arrested at the venue charged with
felony assault for using his cell phone
as a weapon in the NYPD confirmed to
People magazine he will be arraigned
later Monday police confirmed that BB
rexa was taken to a nearby hospital in
stable condition she posted on Instagram
sharing what appeared to be like a
brutal wound yeah I'm saying I'm good in
a nod to her uh latest hit song so she's
handling it like a champ but the footage
is like really upsetting I know it's
wild like I hate this guy yes at first I
couldn't tell if it was like an accident
because you know a lot of artists will
be like give me your phone and like
maybe you know she wanted to like record
something and he tossed it but it was
very like I wasn't sure but then it
looked like it was it was a it was a
phone flying through the air overhand
not underhand but like
so who's gonna pay money to go to a yep
a show where they're gonna use their own
phone to hurt so it it makes no sense it
makes no sense I know and it's like it's
not like even something you can do
anonymously it's your phone we just open
it up and see who's in the background we
know it's you yeah you can't get away
with this sort of like I want to know
like was this fully premeditated and how
long like where's he planning it for
weeks days that's what people are so
deeply unwell no 100 and and as someone
who toured yeah I know it's my worst
nightmare wait the other night when we
were on stage all of the sudden there
was this deep
giant ominous scream oh my God from
someone in the audience we thought it
was like I thought it was it yeah we
thought like and all of a sudden they
were going um
you're just uh
worm with a mustache
no I thought it was it was over it was
like the Great and Powerful Oz sounding
in this in the audience and me Beau and
Taylor froze and I thought this is it
like this is fully it I I couldn't even
like get the words out to be like
everybody get under your seat get under
your seat and it was somebody saying
you're just a worm with a mustache so I
totally know what you're talking about
it's like the the littlest things when
you're on stage you're so vulnerable
like yeah the littlest things like a
footstep or somebody getting up to go to
the bathroom yeah that freaks me out
like sometimes I'll I'll hear people
like walking just so I go to the bar go
to the bathroom but it sounds because of
like the echo on the stage it sounds
like they're coming from behind me and
it freaks me out I'm like always like on
edge and it's hard because you're like
trying to perform and like you know
entertain people but you're so on edge
that I know exactly like sometimes just
the tone of someone's voice at the very
beginning can just set you off and make
you think you're in danger yes so for
something like this to actually happen
oh my God it's my worst nightmare I feel
so bad for her and she's like having
such a good attitude about the whole
thing like how does she ever go and
perform again I don't know I would be
like that that's it for me I know that's
it I mean music concerts are more
um like high energy and I feel like
crazier things happen at music concerts
but still like how do you even prevent
this from happening you sound like
yeah I don't know I'm like I'm so this
is like such an upsetting story yeah and
I her her face looks like it's like a
full-blown black eye stitches yeah her
eye is purple it's like bulging it's
like a major you just think a phone is a
phone but a phone is very heavy yes and
when and when it's being thrown shucked
and when you least expect it you're
singing in your cute outfits yeah I feel
so bad for her yeah it's really
upsetting and I really hope she's okay
um and like honestly I I hope this man
gets what's coming to him so that it
like discourages anyone else from doing
this completely because if people think
they can get away with stuff like this
people are not well yes I know people
are insane I'm like I have three shows
left now I'm [__] scared I know I
have to I can't lie like I can't wait
for your tour to be over like you've
took away like my friends sorry I don't
have a lot I'm sorry literally only
three days left three three shows left
where are the remaining shows are there
tickets available I don't I don't know
that there's tickets available it's La
uh oh that's a big one second birthday
it's my birthday that's exciting well
I'm scared about that one because I feel
like if there are people that don't like
me they're gonna be in LA and like if
they wanted to show up and throw a phone
at me that would be the location not to
like be so self-promotional but did you
ever read my book it's okay if you
didn't I did not that's totally fine so
there is a uh by the way I'm literally
nice idea what there it is you didn't
send me one I didn't no so if so I need
to go home but I'm not I'm not offended
in the slightest like I swear to God I
don't take it personally like my husband
like I had to literally hold it onto his
head for him to read my book I know what
I'm it's fine but there is a story in
there actually that has to deal with
Taylor strecker when I got canceled
um I had like no work and I had no money
coming in so like the only thing I could
really do to like generate revenue and
just like get out of my house was to do
live shows which is like the scariest
thing yeah because you just think you
know that you're you always think your
situation is worse than it is but like
mine was pretty bad and I was like
everyone hates me everyone hates me and
Taylor schrecker called me like the day
of my show and she was like I do not
want to give you a pit like I don't want
to give you anxiety but I just heard
this thing and I just I didn't want I
didn't know what to do with this
information so like I have to give it to
you she's like somebody I forget who it
was but it was somebody like a reputable
who like works in the industry had told
Taylor strecker that there were people
were planning to protest outside my my
show and she was like
I don't know what you want to do but
like I just thought I should tell you
I'm like oh my God thank you I was so
panicky I mean I had no choice it was
literally the day of the show it ended
up raining really bad that night and
nobody ever protested and I don't know
if that's because the rumor was a lie or
because you know my sense of
self-importance was just like you know
way blown out of proportion or because
it was raining
um but it was the scariest night in my
life Claudia the way I would have
probably canceled I know I thought about
it like that is that's terrifying
especially I know what that feels like
yeah when you're in a situation when
you're canceled and but it's like
canceled but people get so invested that
like they become maniacal yes and you
you literally do fear for your life at
times the thought of somebody like doing
something crazy and like bringing a
knife or something is not that far not
far-fetched like it happens to people
quite often yeah yes far more than you
would think than it does yes so that
just reminded me of yes to have that
panic but no your La show is gonna be
amazing and you're doing the well turn
uh no we did the wheelchair I'm doing
the Ace Hotel I've done it it's
that's what everyone says all the photos
that I keep looking at I'm like oh it
looks like the Gilded yes it's so you
yeah whatever happened to the show The
Gilded Age I feel like I was coming back
is it yeah when
um I just know that it is okay because I
researched to be and you know it wasn't
canceled I know for a fact it was not
okay it was not as good as I wanted it
to be but I it still fed my soul and it
got much better like I do think the
second season will be very good yeah I
think so too like the first the first
few episodes where they were like
setting the scene I was like my God this
is so [__] boring I think that like
what made it kind of like not what I
thought is like you look at something
like Downton Abbey and they have like
the real location yeah it's like you're
seeing the you're seeing the actual
place Castle you're seeing the grounds
whereas on um Gilded Age there was so
much like cji yeah and sets that like no
that's actually a really good point that
to me it like kind of took us out of it
and actually a good segue into our next
story is I think one of the things that
everyone did was Cynthia Nixon being in
it I agree with you not because she's a
bad actress I love Cynthia next but
she's too famous yeah to play anything
other than Miranda I completely agree
with you which is a great segue into our
next story Sarah Jessica Parker and
Kristen Davis are both speaking out
about Kim Cattrall's big return we heard
from Kim we did not hear from the other
ladies and now we have so she uh spoke
to page six and said according to uh I
mean after Kim Cattrall's return she
says it's been a lot of Joy okay
that's what she had to say about Kim
Cattrall's brief appearance she also
said it was really fun and exciting and
certainly nostalgic
okay that the follow-up is better yeah
but
in no way has been a lot of joy for SJP
no I have like a theory and I don't
think it's like that far-fetched because
it's been made it like clear that like
the narrative is that Kim Cattrall is
the one who's difficult none of the
other ladies got along with her so it's
like when three people say you're
difficult you're difficult you know so I
understand that's how it works but I can
totally see a world in which Sarah
Jessica Parker is the villain of this
story and like Kim Cattrall is a victim
I know I sound crazy maybe I'm just
biased maybe I'm also you don't sound
crazy this is like a little more popular
of an opinion than you would think but
maybe I'm also just seeing the situation
through the lens of their characters
which is not fair
I know I think it's because Sarah
Jessica Parker gives like um
like trying it's like she's always
trying to look like the goodies shoes
one yeah you know what I mean it's and
nobody's like that sorry no one's like
that all the time especially like a big
Hollywood star yes like it's okay like
we want to see a little bit of realness
we want to see a little bit of cattiness
like oh like it's it's real no one is
that good all the time I agree and I
think that's what so people like start
to see through it yes I think it's like
the same thing that like the same
problem that people have with Meghan
Markle yeah is that like they're like
where's the relatability you're just
trying to be so perfect and perfect
that's actually a really good comparison
what do you think about her podcast
drama
[__] wild it's wild no it's like it's
like really wild and that that guy
what's his name Bill Simmons or oh from
the ringer yes yeah who is now a Spotify
executive coming out what are you
calling them [__] grifters well I
mean I don't think it could be
considered a grift because I don't think
they got paid their full contract
because they didn't deliver what you
don't just get paid immediately you get
paid once you deliver and and finish
certain requirements of you so I think
they maybe got like five or six or seven
million but they definitely didn't get
the full 20. I mean I but I also feel
like when you sign a contest with Bill
Simmons who said that yeah he started
the ringer yes when they got acquired by
Spotify yeah yeah yeah yeah I just think
that when they signed that contract they
had to have talked about the fact that
okay we're gonna do 12 episodes like I
don't think that that was news to anyone
yeah you know what I mean yeah I I do
think I mean I listened to the podcast
and I'm a huge Meghan Markle fan so I
wanted to like it so bad I know I really
I tried so hard but I think what she's
missing is that relatability I think
she's scared to to be honest like really
be honest and to really like let her her
flaws show because people are just
pounce anytime she does anything exactly
and I understand that she's in that
position I understand why she doesn't
want to show any weakness or anything
that that she feels people could
criticize but that is what we want to
see no and that's what really like
that's what podcasting is it was so
overproduced and so scripted and like so
it felt like a like a TV show yeah
that's not what podcasting is podcasting
is sitting here and me being like pull
your mic closer like it's so yeah it's
like feeling like you're in the room
with them and you're friends with them
you're talking or you're a fly on the
wall yeah and it was not that and now
it's also coming out that like you know
her voice was actually like added in
later I knew that I could tell by
listening to it I'm like oh she didn't
interview a lot of these people some of
them she did yeah but like some of them
know like did you read Andy Cohen's
recent book no I think you would like it
well I feel like it's like weird because
you have like a thing with Andy like you
obviously know him but it's actually a
really good book it's a lot about
Parenthood so I feel like you would like
that okay but there's a thing about
Meghan Markle in it that I found so
interesting interesting tell me so he
did her podcast yes and he had said um
they did this really long interview and
he brought up uh he said were you silent
or were you silenced and he was like
really proud of himself for just like
putting that in and then they get to the
podcast it actually comes out and they
cut out his Oprah thing he was really
upset about that yeah but then before
they aired her inter his interview on
the podcast Megan gives you know one of
her like pre-recorded spiels right
basically saying how she was kind of
nervous to interview Andy because she
feels like podcast not podcast excuse me
Housewives and Bravo like hasn't been
great for women and like feminism and he
was like what the [__] like you never
said that to me in the interview and
like maybe if you did we would have had
a much more complex and dynamic and
interesting conversation and the podcast
wouldn't have been so [__] boring
right but like to say that as like a
precursor to the interview and then not
bring it up it's like so tacky and and
maybe there is a conversation to be had
actually I hate that I hate that
sentiment that people say Housewives is
bad for women like I don't agree with
that but like to say it and then not say
it to my face is like so cowardly I
didn't know that I know it was so
interesting I know I feel like she just
keeps making like
all the wrong decisions yes and like I
will forever root for her I really
because I feel like she's in an
impossible situation situation and she's
backed herself into this corner yeah
like I think deep down she like what she
really wants is to do good for the world
she wants to live a good life a peaceful
life I'm sure she loves wealth and and
nice things and that's fine all the rest
of us like that uh there's nothing wrong
with that I just wish like um I could be
her publicist and I could be like listen
my strategy for you is to like just you
need to like reel it up you need to just
like show people who you are or don't or
pull back don't pull back and don't be
doing docu-series books but they have to
make money I know that's what they have
in order to make money is their story
and their stories like that's yeah
that's what it is no you're 100 right
it's like a it's honestly a terrible
position to be in I just wish more
people would have compassion for them
because like yes they are incredibly
[__] privileged but we have no idea
what it's like to be hairy yeah or Megan
or to be a royal and if they were to go
if she was to go and try and act right
now she'd be criticized and made fun of
and that was that was what she knew so
what do we expect her to do no that's
fair that's fair but if she won't kind
of break down that fourth wall and like
be like an honest vulnerable vulnerable
person which is easier said than done
yeah then I don't think these projects
are the right projects for her correct
yeah yeah no but that's a good point
um and then just lastly Charlotte from
Sex in the City this is what she said
she told the telegraph last week that
while she understands fans are upset Kim
Cattrall doesn't have a bigger role in
the spin-off she doesn't have any strong
feelings about it she said I'm not gonna
waste energy on it I can't change
anybody I do understand the fans's
feelings that they're upset I wish I
could fix it but I can it's not in my
power
you know I just I don't know like I I
just it reminds me all of like
Vanderpump Rules and like when I'm like
not friends with someone I feel like I
relate to Kim control in this situation
that's very easy comparing myself to
kids
but like
I've I have felt on the outside so many
times but I feel like the reasons why
are valid like I'm hurt by certain
things I'm choosing to be on the outside
and then the people that are are I guess
I'm I'm against or I'm I'm opposing yeah
yes I don't know arguing this their
their argument is like well we can all
get along we're all friends so if you're
the one with the problem and it's like
no each of you guys has hurt me I'm
deciding to not to not be a part of that
anymore like I choose to have people in
my life that I feel like I can trust and
and bring happiness and good and enrich
it instead of take from it but like so
if that means but I'm the only one on
the outside so therefore I must be the
bad guy you know by the way it's totally
giving Vanderpump Rules and I don't
think it's so crazy to say that like
Vanderpump Rules especially in like the
early days with like Jax Kristen you Tom
like
I don't think it's crazy to say that
like Brandon prep worlds was the Sex and
the City of Our Generation like I I
don't think that's the craziest thing to
say do you oh my God you can say it I
can't yeah no you can't but but like I
am gonna start thinking it
you are definitely there's something
there there's there's oh my god
oh no well maybe because if you look
back I was the absolute worst you know
like I was the one in the moment
they love to hate me no actually you
were like always acting like an animal
But like everyone like nobody cared like
they just like loved you no matter what
you did you know like it kind of is
giving Capri
I think it is oh my God and you grew up
into a Samantha slash Miranda thank you
that's I think that's a good place to
leave it you know
our fifth and final story is some Barbie
movie news I'm obsessed with the Barbie
movie I would love to get your take on
it and they did like a really cute smart
little promo thing for it with
architectural digest so the Barbie dream
house has opened its doors Margot Robbie
hosted a tour of Barbie's iconic home in
a new video for architectural digest
ahead of the theatrical release of the
live-action Barbie film
um and kind of how they do those like
celebrity home tours they did one for
Barbie's house I think it's so cute so
she they showed off the over-the-top
dream house which features a pool a bold
pink kitchen a peekaboo peek-a-boo
Peek-a-boo view of Barbie's Neighbors
on the set of the film while she was
dressed in character in a light pink and
blue checkered cropped jacket
high-waisted mini skirt and a hat she
looked so cute her kitchen is uh has a
pink fridge a round pink breakfast table
she said not super practical but nothing
is her Barbie I'm just obsessed with
this
um
I think this was like the smartest promo
I I thought it was so smart on on ads
part I thought it was so smart on
Barbie's part I cannot wait to see this
oh I'm so excited and everybody who who
criticized that because I feel like I've
already heard criticism yeah mainly
about Ryan Gosling yeah I am not
understanding first of all did Ken have
an age that I was unaware of um okay so
I feel like you're talking directly to
me because I was very critical of Ryan
Gosling at all and I'll explain
Ken didn't have an age exactly but Ken
was Flawless and I'm sorry
Ryan Gosling is extremely hot he's not
Flawless like who would you cast
I forget who said this and I don't want
to take credit for it but I thought it
was an amazing call Austin Butler
he's not Flawless no he literally
doesn't have a wrinkle in sight like not
to be ageist or anything but like sorry
he I don't think that he's old you don't
think Austin Butler's that hot not
really I mean I I think he was hot
recently when he got like a spray tan
for the Oscars and I'm like oh I love a
spray tan but you might have loved him
as Ken like I'm just saying somebody
with a perfect face like
who Jacob a lordy do I was thinking that
too he has like a really nice like Ken
looking face yeah but not to be mean but
like when you look at Margot Robbie her
face is perfection there's not a thing
out of place like she literally looks
like a Barbie doll
Ryan Gosling like was just giving like
not like perfection
and I know Perfection is like an
unattainable standard but Margot Robbie
did it flawlessly correct okay no I'm
just I love Ryan Gosling so much insane
that's oh it's like you know it's like
when you complain about Blake Lively in
the new yes it ends with us it's just
yeah you can still love black Lively but
just think it's like the wrong thing
what do you think about that casting did
you read the book I didn't read the book
but like I have no interesting because
you're such a big reader well I've
fallen off a little bit I haven't read a
book in
four months really hit me back on it
okay I I need to like get back on I need
to read like weird things right like
historical fiction yeah but I also like
you guys recommended a lot of [__] that
that wasn't historical fiction that I
ended up reading and really loved like
honestly most of the books that I was
reading I found through you guys or your
fans well then I have a list for you
please what's your favorite type of book
well historical fiction oh well uh but
like do you like Thrillers I do I love
Thrillers you like smut like romance
books I'm not really into that I made a
mistake huge I mean I could like try and
get there okay yeah I need to like get
on the wagon again yeah I feel like
pregnancy is such a perfect time for
reading now I've been busy yeah you have
but you've also been traveling a lot and
travel is the perfect time for for
reading yeah no good point missed
opportunity there missed opportunity
okay it's fine do you ever read The Rose
code
the rose coat I don't think I heard it's
like a popular historical fiction book
that I have to read for my book club and
I'm like dreading it because I hate
historical fiction so I was wondering if
you had read it oh that sucks that you
hate historical fiction I know I mean I
don't hate it I just never choose it but
I've read quite a few that I loved but
it's just never what I reach for I
always reach for like a thriller well
like television shows what do you reach
for everything like I'm I have a wide
spectrum like I do love like Downton
Gilded Age but I love you know
unscripted I love I'm watching shrinking
now I love it I love Ted lasso I watch
everything no literally historical
fiction is the only thing I reach for in
like all categories in TV too yeah
movies everything like you love
Bridgerton yes it's like the only thing
that makes me feel like I I I truly am
excited about the content that I'm even
my Tick Tock algorithm yeah I can
imagine Darkness everywhere
um well what are your thoughts on the
Barbie movie in terms of like the
trailer we've gotten like what do you
think it's gonna be good oh yes you know
I think it's gonna be [__] perfect
Margaret Robbie like doesn't make bad
movies I mean well
but I don't know lately I feel like
these aren't they're a little artsy
they're not like hitting yeah with like
the the rest of us basic yes [__] you
know what I mean but I feel like her big
budget blockbuster movies are always
good like I Tonya like when she's doing
the most for a movie yeah no you know I
just I don't see how Barbie could be a
flop I know I I just I don't see a world
where especially because they've been
trying to get this movie made in so many
different ways for so long that like
they're not gonna half-ass it no and
Visually it looks so beautiful yeah I
mean is it really true that like they
were how to paint a pink paint shortage
in the world because of the Barbie movie
did you read this I didn't they said
that there was a pink paint shortage in
the world because of the Barbie movie
because they wanted everything the pink
to be so vibrant right I mean I believe
that but I also feel like for the last
few years there's just been like
shortages of everything and they're like
covid China you know like like there was
literally a shortage of glitter remember
like there's a short there's a shortage
of there was a shortage of glitter there
was a shortage of like washing machines
and cars because of like the microchips
that have to go in it like there was a
shortage of everything isn't that weird
that we lived through covid no no do you
like think about it like
sometimes I go I'll sit back and think
about like people were so tense and so
like high strung and like fighting about
everything online and like you know when
I think about some of the [__] like
people used to like like Riot over on
the internet like if that happens again
like you guys like people were so deeply
unwell like it's humiliating no it's
literally like we lived through the
bubonic Blade no literally like by the
way wild I literally had dinner after
after being quarantined in in May I had
dinner with my family outside we sat
outside I remember listening we
referenced this on the toes we all
walked we sat outside we had been
quarantined for 60 days not seeing
another human we had a meal outside
you would have thought yeah committed
genocide yeah the way people came for us
and now in hindsight you all look so
stupid and I'm like humiliated for the
people who did that but like it was
terrifying like people came I was like
what and we weren't taking it lightly
like Olivia was nine months pregnant
like we were doing the most like
the way people came for us I was like
and now in hindsight I'm like oh my god
like people were it like covet was
obviously like an illness but it was
also a mental illness away the way uh
quarantine made people [__] nuts nuts
no I completely agree like and now in
hindsight we realize how crazy it was
but like I'm fully I'm waiting for my
apology I think I'll be waiting quite a
while
um well starting I just love chatting
with you I hate that this is oh I know
if there's anything else you want to
chat about like we don't have to be done
I mean I can't like think off the top of
my head but I just love doing this with
you you are welcome back anytime you
know that thank you if you liked what
you heard here sassy is like a huge
podcast by the way I don't know if
you've been the last time you were on
the show you were proning your book was
straight up straight up with Sassy has
made kind of a triumphant return how
does it feel you were one of the first
podcasters not like the first ever but
like in this space honestly it feels
like I just like am new like really I I
do appreciate when people like you are
like give me that that credit yeah
you're an OG you guys are so amazing and
so talented and so successful and I
think like because I didn't have my
podcast for two years like I've I feel
like I'm just new and starting out again
like I'm starting this new business no
way and first of all it's like riding a
bike it is but like it I I forget that I
have been doing it for a long time yeah
also podcasting has changed so much
since the last time you did it 100 I
feel like when you were like really
starting out you like you would always
go into a studio like there was no
podcasting from home I know but like
covid really like expedited like
everybody has like full fancy podcast
setups you film in your house right yeah
like so much change during that time
because of covid but no you're like an
OG podcaster straight up with stassi how
many apps you do one a week one a week
yeah and it's so good and I personally
like the pop culture hour because I'm
obsessed with telestrucker but check it
out straight up with stassi you also
have a patreon which we love patreon
over here it's patreon.com oh that's
such a good link yeah right straight
into them sausage is just so easy it's
so easy how do you feel about like not
being the only famous Stasi and have you
met the other famous sausage no
um what's it called stassi baby yes well
she doesn't go by Saucy baby anymore is
she does it no she like changed all of
her doesn't she go by stoss yes yes do
you think that's because of me I like to
think so I want to think it is too but
like she's like well there's already a
stassi so I'm just have you ever met no
I've never met her but I get confused
for her yeah like when I was like I'm
going in to like renew my my car lease
or whatever like the guy at the
dealership was like so you're famous and
I think that he's
and he'll start being like so Kylie
Jenner
that's not me that's not me you can just
roll with it maybe you'll get you know
you'll cut the line or something like it
is so annoying having another like the
way that I name my babies is like their
name has to be like outside of the five
thousand list I don't want them to have
to share a name with anyone and I just
do you have a name for your baby oh yeah
I think it's done it's done that's done
how did you find it done
um it was actually the last time I was
in New York here it was like the day
before I saw you for Taylor's birthday
we came I came up with it and did you
find it like in a book or something or
oh it just kind of floated into your
mind through a list we had we'd cut
there was a street that I saw oh and I'm
like I like this name but we already
knew someone who was named that so then
we like changed yeah interesting changed
it so let me let me guess is it 7th
Avenue
it is actually a cool name but it's like
a little two out there I think well it
reminds me of Harper seven it reminds me
of seven by Taylor Swift a beautiful
song wait can you tell me how you keep
getting tickets to Taylor Swift the way
I've tried yeah I'll tell you I've gone
through my agency I've gone through
everyone let me tell you the first time
I got a box in Nashville with like 20 of
my friends and we each paid what we
would pay for like a regular ticket and
we all just ended up getting our own box
I literally contacted like a salesperson
for the Nissan Stadium like I like went
through just like the regular channels
the second time I bought them on StubHub
three hours before
it was still very pricey the third time
a brand went and they a brand called
tangle teaser they had purchased a box
and filled with influencers and content
creators so that was that and I think I
will be going one more time I'm not sure
when the [__] I know no the thing is
with with the Taylor tickets like you
can't cut any lines like you just have
to pay for it well no I'm that's fine
I'm just like I don't I didn't want to
just like have a regular seat I wanted
to like I want to I want to purchase the
best experience yes yes and I actually
purchased the best experience on StubHub
okay that's I would say my best tickets
so you're saying that one she when she's
in La I should day up yep so like not
the day before it's like no just get
dressed like I was I knew I was gonna go
no no and then as I'm doing my makeup we
bought the tickets we were monitoring
all day but what if you couldn't find
the tickets and you were ready for
nothing and like that's such a letdown
like I would have found it like one
thing about me like I would have found
the tickets can't you do it for me
credit card info for sure as long as I
can buy one for myself like sure no real
talk that would be my payment to you by
the way done come to California we are
thinking me and Margo um just depending
on like what happens to Jackie's like
birth schedule we are really hoping to
be in La for the August shows great for
Taylor yeah great so maybe I'll see you
there so maybe you literally will be
there yeah okay I'm hoping to be let's
work on we'll coordinate okay um make
sure you're following sassy on all
platforms thank you so much for being
here thank you guys for listening
tomorrow we are in studio with Jax which
is so exciting she hasn't been in studio
in a while so thank you so much for
listening to the test and Landing
Morning Show we deliver the fastest
stories you need to remember Monday
Friday new tips you're watching us on
YouTube please don't describing this
video thumbs up also available
wickedly talented we are hope you guys
an amazing day I'll see all my Boston
girlies tonight for our Spritz event and
have a great day love you bye